hey guys today's video is focused around
one simple question what do you wear to
the White House the problem is by the
time I post this video and I get your
suggestions or your comments or your
feedback I'm already gonna be on my way
to Washington DC so it's going to be
completely helpless so it looks like I'm
on this mission alone but on this
mission you guys are gonna come with me
because that's the joy of vlogging
[Music]
probably one of the coolest features in
some cars now is apple carplay i really
talked about it much
but it's pretty awesome it basically
turns your heads-up display into
seemingly your iPhone so you can do all
kinds of things you can scroll through
your phone your music your maps messages
you can also go to Spotify which is
quite exciting let's browse today's top
hits you've come o to me don't even know
me oh god Bob baby brexit it's my girl
oh this is a good soul all the songs are
good because it's the top hit so clearly
if I can be a bad song was on top it's
not always true why is there traffic
every time I'm surprised every time
parking garage etiquette drives me nuts
if you see a car pulling out and there's
absolutely no other spots that's fine
you can wait for that spot but if
there's other spots it says there's a
hundred and seventy five spots available
keep going no one ever says Justine you
look really nice today they usually say
wow you look really comfortable which
isn't a bad thing because I would rather
be comfortable than look nice so before
we go shopping I need to eat some food
every time I go shopping I realize oh
crap I'm starving so here we are getting
food I just had the best salad of my
life it was the most incredible thing
look I took it for granted when I just
looked at it it was set down in front of
me I was like well this is a pool sale
then I started eating it and wow wow I
haven't even had my coffee food acquired
let's go find something to wear it to
the white house
[Music]
I bought a black sweatshirt please
let me wear sweat pants to the White
House it'll look good I promise it'll
look good
no I didn't find anything you wear
tomorrow I think we have bigger issues
than what I need to wear in the White
House that's a whole nother swert 2017
is the year of not waking up early yet
hmm
so do you guys remember it in
yesterday's vlog when I told you that my
video was gonna be nine and a half hours
long that was a lie it's 33 hours long
that's how much content I made in 2016
this is a fun little fact YouTube only
lets you upload 12 hours maximum per
video the video file has to be less than
128 gigs another part of this little
puzzle was final cut only lets you
export 24 hours of footage at that point
the timeline then resets here's my
timeline let's click inside here because
I made it into a new a new compound clip
so I could try to keep my life organized
here we have our timeline now if we
scroll all the way over here you guys
will notice right here this is how long
the video is so right here this is 9
hours 32 minutes 56 seconds and we keep
keep you keep going let's go to the 24
hour more which is very soon my god my
computer is going to die right here and
there you have it
so what happened the first time when I
export of this video I went all the way
to the end and I saw oh its nine and a
half hours cool that's not that bad but
what really happened is that 24 hours
the timeline reset so it only was
exporting nine and a half hours because
at the end of this whole entire thread
of Clips it said it was nine and half
hours so final cut got super super
confused and said oh cool I'm only gonna
export nine and a half hours of your 33
and that leaves us here to the issue
that I'm having now 33 hours of video
what do I do I cut it in three parts so
right now we're exporting and it took
seven
and a half hours to export part 1 this
might have to be a project for tomorrow
or the next day so stay tuned because
it's gonna be really fun but you could
just watch the playlist of videos from
20 you know what I don't know I just
wanted to see if it could be done so
we'll see what happens but this leaves
us to another issue that we have
I need a Europe amate you might be
wondering more Matias he's at Gemma's
house I missed him so much but Jenna
also missed him so I was doing about
yourself yesterday so she is not my baby
every time that he's not here it's like
a piece of meat is just missing I don't
have to take anyone for a while I don't
have to make him an extra egg for
breakfast so now I need to edit this
vlog but that's gonna cause quite an
issue because I'm exporting this video
and then I won't be able to export the
video that I'm editing so I guess I'll
let it with this the back pro god this
thing is really cool like it is pretty
awesome here's the issue it kind of
sucks for editing and final cut another
one
work work work I don't own this game
thing on perhaps the power of on well
yes that brings me to the end of this
vlog here a message oh oh I just got a
repeater of Maddie sleeping he's so
sweet we had to take him to a babysitter
today I'm gonna miss him so much but he
has so much fun hackers are so many
other doggies and he just has a blast
anyway that's the end of this vlog happy
at 2017 if I haven't said it already I'm
looking forward to posting the full 33
hours of 2016 for you guys I'd also like
to note for those who might be wondering
we're going to the White House and no
Trump will not be there so that's it
I'll see you guys tomorrow and hopefully
what is
overall this computer is all god I'm
getting notifications everywhere I'll
see you guys later I'm flustered
by this is what I look like when I
travel with my dog he's so good he just
sits and waits do you hear me talking
man I'm talking about you
what is that Jenna Maddy's already seep
in
now clearly it's a few days later and
I'm back last night was